everybody through the second day of the
beyond the Boolean Cube Workshop so the
first speaker for today is nam lift it
and he has a very complicated title so
I'm going to read it for my phone he's
going to talk about product mixing
Quantum separation and comfortable
Hunters so take it away now
I'm going to talk about the anti-group
theory so
we're going to have a subset of a group
and
I'm going to say that it is a product
free or an anti-sub group
all a b in a
the product is not in it
so it's the opposite of being a sample
nothing
okay and the following problem was posed
by
Baba and Josh in 1985.
so it was to find the largest
three subset of a group
of a given group
and
it turns out that this problem has lots
of connections to TCS Kevin told me that
it's somehow related to a matrix
multiplication and it's also related to
separation between Quantum and
communication complexity and classical
communication complexity but uh
I'll uh
yeah okay but uh yeah I won't talk too
much about DCS applications I'll just
look at this is a pure math problem
okay
so specifically we're going to talk
about this problem inside and as youn so
remind you what the compassion is
the group
SEO and
is the group of all
SSA
and
that's been made to say such that
if you take the phone's pose and
conjugate multiply by a you get the
identity and
and
also the torment of a is one
another thing that I have to Define is
the how measure I guess so
foreign
new on
xc1
that's left in balance that means that
um
all
measurable a
and
Jane seon
the measure of
GA is the same as the measure of a
this measure is also a writing variant
and this probability measure is called
the harm measure
and then basically gowers he posed a
positive problem not only for finite
groups but extend this problem to all
compact groups or specifically asked
about sum okay so that's
and the conjectures what is the largest
product set
okay so we conjecture a bit
and
if a
is an anti-group inside son
then the measure of a is at most e to
the minus n to the one so e to the minus
n so
okay
the conjecture that the largest products
preset is
going to be exponential in hand
and what he was able to pull
was only something polynomial in
so both n to the minus and one third
and it's poof used a really nice
and
told some representation Theory I need
to do this notion of a quasi random
groups
um
and basically
what
uh we showed so we showed that somehow
hyperconductivity
and
representation Theory and we use this
notion of quite Randomness from
quite random groups
Vision Theory
what we showed is that they sort of go
well together and when you combine them
you get much more power and what we
proved is the following so
this theorem is by
okay thanks
guy
in the door
show that if a
subset of s-u-n
then the measure of a
is it most
um if a
is productively
measure base at most e to the minus c n
to the one over
vulnerable
foreign
[Music]
X and then you can take the set of all G
such that and you can also choose I
guess subset of X and then take set of
all group elements such that uh
yeah also too thick as x in x and you
can take this at all group elements G
that send X to I
and eye to eye complement
conjunction I guess that this set is
always sharp up to a constant
and I should move it here I know okay so
containing x x in x
and the set of all elements
such that g of X is in I and G of I is
containing I complement
we called it a kid layer set and we
conjecture that this set is always the
largest product preset up to a constant
and
basically in in Sun you have to choose
the set I carefully and you can show
that you get a set something of majority
it's a sphere
SEO and obviously acts on the sphere and
then you look at the cap
and you want the center of the cut
uh and okay okay so without got stuck in
eight minus CNN
to the one over three but in some sense
it and there was a good reason why it
was stuck there you can take a look at
the product mixing building of this
problem so
and
so that's another feeling
so we can take
um three sets
a b and c okay
the of measure
listed to them at least that
[Music]
then
if you choose
a random yeah so if you choose a random
element a in a and then a random element
B and B
and the mobility that the products
agency
exactly the same as the measure of six
in 0.9 to the 1.1
so this is like a stronger version of
the theorem for 4x3 sets it's called
Product mixing and this result is sharp
so
that's why we got stuck there
and it turned out that this problem was
independent just by physicists so they
had like this
Quantum communication protocol
and they wanted to show that the
classical uh version of any classical
communication protocol for this problem
will be exponentially worse and this was
the tool that they needed but didn't
know how to prove and and
basically this solves the problem they
conjecture something wrong I think the
conjecture that is with one half but
dancers and
yeah but
it's and to the one over three and this
is sharp
that ends with one over three is related
I can explain it when we get there
hopefully
and
and with
um
we also were able to get an improved
Quantum separation so basically there is
something that
um
algorithm
[Music]
communicate
in the one clean qubit and
Logan and foreign
classically it's hard
so basically we need a polyam
so I want to go into details about that
because I don't know anything about that
but yeah I mean it was I was really
lucky like
the summons Institute asked me to Mentor
Uma and then asked her to give me some
problems in sun because we had this
theorem and then and then she sort of
told me about this problem that's
related to this problem and we thought
about it together and
it looks like
we can solve it okay
yeah exactly
yeah
for any sets and
and this holds out the product three
because you get the product free case is
with b and c equal to a and then you get
the probability that A B is in c0 so
and
no
yeah yeah
we also have a version
[Music]
well you have two sets and you want to
show that atoms B is uh is close to
uniform total variation distance and
then the right answer is a to the minus
wooden
yeah
we basically tell you everything you
want to know about mixing but for the
product resets you need something more
I guess I'll talk about the poof
so I'll just recall error Notions home
representation Theory
so let V be a vector space
we denote
a glv
and the set of invertebral matrices
already
okay and then a representation
is a map
ISM from energy to
glv
and equivalently you can say the
following so
equivalently
you have a and
multiplication map from
G times V to V
and this multiplication map is linear so
G of alpha B plus
the io is Alpha GV plus beta jio
and
and it's also associative so
Edge GV is the same as age of GB
foreign
presentation
[Music]
is in V Prime for all BNB Prime
and
the example that we look at is L2 of G
so we have this space
and L2 of G so that's that set of
functions and
G
such that
okay
it does expectation so if we take a
random element in a mu the expectation
of f x squared is finite
so here it's finally not just a notation
but it actually has a meaning with this
L2
so
okay this space of functions this is a
um
yes
yeah so
in this case we call V like a g model
if
um and L2 of G is a g model but it's a g
model in two ways so
we have a map of the form GF of X is
just the F of G in both of X so that's a
representation
this is called the left
we'll call it the left representation
and we also have a right representation
so
G of X is a f x g
foreign
but are there any questions
so let's talk about the governor's
observation
so this idea was to Define an operator
ta
so let's say that a sample a subset of
your group
can be
and then you can look at the operator TA
of f
which is the expectation
of a and a
of f of ax
we Define this operator and then use the
fact that the TA is a right
morphism
okay
I also need to Define so that means that
ta
of FG
the same as TAF
oh
so if you multiply from the left you're
going to compute with multiplication
from the right and
so how is that useful
okay then the idea was to say that
um
so if
a is product free
let F be the indicator of a
and then
but
then we get the TA of f in the product
with f is zero
and the Gauss idea was somehow to show
that this operator
and basically when you have
this is like
the operator corresponds to the random
mark on the graph
and when the graph is pseudo random you
expect this operator that Associated to
it to be approximated by the expectation
operator and then you expect this thing
to be the expectation of f squared
rather than zero so
um
that was
his observation and how did he use this
representation Theory
and
so use the following fact so one fact is
that
if you take the trace
of T A Star
ta
this is going to be
one over and
yeah okay so this operator is a
self-adjoint and turns out that it has
only discreetly many eigenvalues and you
can sum them up and you get that this
thing here is one over the measure of a
and
and now you can
look at
the maximum
it's not much fine so you take super
overall f
with expectation zero
that are non-zero
of a
TAF two Norm
divided by the two Norm of f so that's
called the operator Norm of that and
this is going to be
um
most
the trace of this
foreign
divided
by the multiplicity
of the largest eigenvalue of ta star
yes it turns out this quantity is just
equal
to the largest eigenvalue
um of txta ta
and
maybe you need to text quotes
it's fine okay yeah so uh yeah so this
thing here is just equal to the maximal
eigenvalue and then you can upper bound
the maximal eigenvalue by the trace
divided by the multiplicity because all
Diagon values are positive
so let's just write it the this equals
to Lambda Max
foreign
that's why it's upper bounded by this
[Music]
you don't need to scroll right okay
the left side I swear yeah okay
and then everything here is fine okay
[Music]
um
how is this useful you can basically say
that yeah so you can expand the f
as the expectation of f
plus F minus the expectation of f
and what this means is that this
operator it kills the part of f that's
not constant it kills this part and but
then basically everything is reflective
the expectation of expert
foreign
basically now you just need to combine
everything together you have the bounded
place
and okay and
the final thing here is just that you
want to make this effective so we need
to lower bound the multiplicity and this
is a platform representations
yeah so every
presentation
[Music]
like that um
so okay so we need the following so
every eigenfunction
of
ta star
PA
is the right representation
of su1
that's one fact
and also it's an untrivial one so
you always have the trivial
representation where G of V is equal to
B for all aging but
and if you take every eigen function
except for this one
and this correspond to constant function
you're going to get a non-trivial right
representation of sum
and yes that's
it
now he's getting space again
okay cool
yeah so every eigenspace is a
non-trivialized representation of son
and the second fact is that
each such space
as you mentioned at least then
and when you combine all of this
together you get a Gauss bounded in Sun
the measure of every product reset as is
at most n to the minus one field
yeah
I still I think be able to explain what
is exponential in enter the minus one
field come from
are there any questions about gaussbook
don't you have to
constant I can
so the constant one yeah so yeah so
except for this one so every eigen space
um
yeah but let's say let's click it to l0
so basically
but they don't contribute enough to make
the trace large
I know because this one of them UI is
already large and you have yeah you have
one eigenvalue in it yes
are there any more questions
so so now we'll talk about this
relationship between this
conductivity
foreign
space
so in the wooden Cube we have the space
of low degree polynomials
and you can do the same thing over Sun
but then there is a
subtle
there is some subtlety in the way that
you define the notion of a low degree
polynomial
so let's do it so we say that
bit most DG is the space
of polynomials
in the entries of the input
and the conjugates
foreign
so it's important to also allow
um
yeah so we have the
the function that sends a matrix a to
um a11 this one is of degree one but
also the the
function that said a to a11 conjugate
this is also
um a function degree one and there is
this Duality between
between a
functions of degrees and you can always
take it up conjugate and the dimension
are going to stay the same so we have to
Define it like that
okay so that's
how you define a functions of degree
at mostly so they correspond to the same
thing in the Boolean Cube
and
then you can Define the degree exactly
the part of G
to be the intersection of the atmos D of
G
orthogonal complement to the functions
of degree D minus one so basically take
the all the functions of the degree at
mostly that our orthogonal third
functions of the atmos D minus one
and basically if you look at the Boolean
Cube you see that the number of
monomials of degrees and choose D so
it's basically going with the
and it's going rapidly and we get that
the largest multiplicity we have here
the happier we are we have a smaller
eigenvalue
and then
and basically our idea yeah so
they're like two philosophies I guess
that we took from Boolean functions so
one is that
um
one is that uh
the high dimensions
correspond to high degrees
that's one
and
the second philosophy is that if you you
have if f is the indicator of a and a
small
then
and if Mass
should be contemplated on the categories
oh
that's L2 Mass oops Yeah
and we did manage to prove both of these
facts
so we had one representation theoretic
theorem and one analytic ingredient that
together you can use them to pop the few
lamps one theorem is that um
if we take a sub-representation of the
space V equal to the
mentioned so one thing I think that you
didn't mentioned is that the vehicle to
the is an eigenant space of
so as I mentioned at least
[Music]
yes so so
guys either
this space of degraded it as this
analytic purposes this space of
polynomials but also is a natural object
in in the context of representation
Theory because if you start with a
degree polynomial
and you multiply from G you act from G
by the left or from the right you still
get a degree polynomial so this is a sub
representation of L double G from both
sides
yes that's and one fact that we put that
every sub representation of it has a
large dimension
other analytical ingredient is a level
inequality
and
be the indicator of a and right mu a
to be Alpha
and for technical reasons we also need
the degree to be at most root and
it will actually be interesting to
extend it to the app to linear name
then if we take the projection
of f to the space b equal to D
it's two Norm
it's the level so we get exactly the
same thing that you get for delivered
inequality in the Boolean Cube so this
is at most and
Alpha squared
and slog one over Alpha
the D
with some absolute confidence
I guess also D needs to be at most
logo one over Alpha
so are there any questions
all right
cool
Yeah so basically
[Music]
is there like some L4 Norm or something
combined with the fact that if it's cool
yeah and so you so we prove the
hypocontractively that and so it proved
yeah I can stay this theorem as well so
um
yeah so there exists
a noise operator
that's that um
if y is at most
and one of us quote Q minus one
UF
a queue is at most
E2 Norm of f
that's one thing that's important that
it has conduction probabilities but
right now it doesn't mean anything
because this operator table could could
be the expectation operator
but so it has also has an additional
property
that if
f is of the greedy
that is in
be equal to the
then
the two Norm of
evil f
is at least
awesome absolute constant
ly
and the last part is for the utmost
wooden
and we conjunction with the same
operator that we constructed will have
this this property for the maybe
absolutely elements and
and when we Mark is that I said
everything for sun but actually
everything holds for every company group
s for and
every compact
group
female dimension
system
thank you
that's almost all but yeah I mean
you have to replace maybe a g bytes
Universal cover to get everything the
same and otherwise you have to replace
this
if you want to enter the one third two
and one over six maybe but yeah
essentially everything holds for Apple
compactly groups in the same way
and you mean
I mean
you just set n to be the minimum
Dimension the question Randomness
parameter
so now let's just explain how a result
for product presets how it uh
let me just show the proof
so that was defined this operator OTA
that so you can generalize it
so you can also Define this operator TF
level t f of G
is
product mix
so t f of G is f convolution with Gene
which is the expectation of and
okay double X of f of x g x inverse y
y here everyone
and so if f is the indicator of some set
then this is the same as
Let's ignore the interval says so
basically we start with
functions now f
G and H
and we want to show that
t f g inner product with age so let's go
show that this is a roughly the
expectation of f times the expectation
of G times the expectation of H
uh
okay so one fact that we are going
through is that this thing decomposes
nicely so we know that if we take the
inner product between f and g it's the
sum of the inner product between the
degree part of F and the degree part of
G that's just because it's a projection
but it also behaves well with respect to
this operator
we take tsg now for the h
which is the sum of all the
of TF equal to D
to D
H equal to D
and then we had this fact about the
trace of taste RTA this also generalizes
so
the price of TF star TF
which is going to be the two Norm of f
squared
whatever that
and okay so now our goal will be to show
that foreign
this part I want to show that this is
negligible
okay so does anyone have an idea what to
do here with this expression
and to somehow relate this to TF Style
okay
yeah so yeah
okay so we can say that
this t f equal to D
oh and D equal to the inner product with
Edge equal to D
the most TF equal to D
is equal to the two norms
times H equal to D2 Norm
and that's at most t f equal to D
and this
to two Norm
s
is equal to the two norms
is equal to the tuna okay so the two to
two Norm is defined exactly like that
the the number that satisfies this
property and
so uh
yeah yeah
just for the people that don't know
operators yeah anyways
I didn't say it was though
and okay and now we can so this is the
yeah so we said that this is the square
root of the maximum eigenvalue of
square root of that Maxima of Lambda Max
of TF equal to D star DF equal to D
and then we can use this we can use this
and yes we have we said this is at most
F equal to D two Norm
divided by the multiplicity of Lambda
Max
and eventually you get that
and eventually you'll get just F equal
to D two Norm D equal to D two Norm
is equal to D two Norm
divided by and then minimal dimension
for example presentation
V equal to D
ude
okay
so yeah and okay and now basically yeah
the result is follows so let's just uh
see what's going on when D is equal to
one
so basically when D is equal to one
the dimension
is equal to n
and
basically what the governors did was
essentially to say that we have the
degree one part of the function
that was just said okay this is at most
the two Norm of f which is the
um
square root of the expectation of f
and and what we did was to say
we said that the level one
foreign this is at most
in
the expectation of f
that's log 1 over the expectation of f
okay so we're comparing this thing with
the expectation of f cubed
yeah
and yeah so we are comparing the this
thing with the application of f Cube so
basically if you don't get the right
dependence on the expectation you
um
you will get only something polynomial
in n but here we get this log factor
that competes with this end and that's
why
are these level one inequality
level one equality tells you that the
square is most expectations of f
Yeah so basically you have the slope
factor that fights this n
and you get a slope back to three times
or maybe one and a half times until you
get a half time the
the dimensions so you have three logs
that fight this end and that's why
to get you everything works up to 80
minus 10 to 1 3.
and the
and basically if you want to improve
everything like it's sharp in every
degree basically so you're going to do
that so we'll have to in order to
improve on that field somehow have to
come up with the new ideas
okay yeah
when this is
then you get
um yeah
looks well
okay so I think I'll stop here
foreign
and so we showed that pillow is I feel
complex
via a coupling technique
so I talked about it in the boot camp if
you have one operator the type of
conductive so we start with the hyper
constructive operator in gaussian space
and we couple it with a son essentially
by Gram Schmidt and then you get a hyper
protective operator on sun that's
hyperconductive for free and the main
difficulty is getting the second
property that the FF is in a vehicle
today then
okay POF then people doesn't kill it
is at least
so that's like the main difficulty
and then we use a lot of representation
Theory basically to compute uh Italian
value so this operator now commutes with
the action of and of the group only from
one side so the first thing is to
symmetrize it and to make it commute
with the action also from the other side
as well and we still get something hyper
compactive
and then this comfortable definitely
come up when you want to and calculate
the eigenvalues they basically show that
the
build
yeah I can Define what comfortable so
it's a function of the form so we sum
over accommodations in SD or
hey Sigma
full
the product of
a micro
so what these are the comfortable
defunders so why are they called
comfortable deep Hunters they are
different because they only depend on
the upper defense they minor of The
Matrix
so they depend only on the coordinates
in some sense
and uncomfortable because they are
multilinear we know that in general if
you want to work with a
these functions are
um
they also have this extra property the
monomials correspond to different rows
and different economies and turns out
that
it makes them really nice for when you
try to compute the eigenvalues or
comfortable to work with
and any more questions
about the content the point is that
every eigenspace uh of every against
expenses so that's why and that requires
some of the presentations
is this actually five from one to D so
yeah yeah
same thing with the Sun or something
else
and a sigma it depends on Sigma so it
comes from this young symmetalizers
the thing is how do you prove more than
for sub representation
and okay so we had two
two approaches basically in the papers
one of them is to take some close
formulas for the dimensions and
I guess
like representations it was mostly care
about the case where uh and it's fixed I
don't think of a sympathetic the high
dimension so nobody ever tried to
compute the synthetics of this Dimension
so that's like and
one thing but another approach actually
uses this comfortable differences we
sort of say that and each eigen says or
each each representation contains this
and then we can show that we can
shift it by element of G and get lots of
linear linearly Independence functions
and that gives you a lot about the
dimensions
yes the will take further questions of
land so let's thank them again
[Applause]
foreign
yes